[Music]
people often say van Lube is
death-defying no or not
what we do is life-affirming it
celebrates the human spirit and grace
and beauty and courage I'm not a
daredevil I am a dance maker
[Music]
Vanda loop is a dance company that for
25 years now has been merging the worlds
of rock climbing Mount Mary with concert
stage dance and bringing these worlds
together we're able to dance in the
mountains or on buildings but in ways
that activate those spaces in unusual
and wonderful ways they got the other
fans now back to you it takes a lot of
work to make a dream into reality doing
the hard work finding the right people
practicing failing failing failing
succeeding having the tenacity to keep
going and trying to make something
that's sort of an idea reel
the newest member of the company is a
young woman named Virginia Broyles since
I was a kid I was always interested in
how people moved and how to move my own
body the more I learned about bandar
loop the more it made sense to me
because I'm not losing any of the dance
that I love so much I'm just getting to
do it in this other relationship to
gravity
I picked her because she has a really
high capacity to learn fast
take movement into her body which is
sort of like what I call a physical
intelligence the rotation and the loft
and jumping and all these things are
really exciting and fun and then the
next step is like going on a building
and I was like oh yeah I really want to
do this and then the voice is like okay
like but is being on a building and it
just be like way too much dance you
dance dancer with each other
I definitely feel adrenaline walking up
to the wall before performances you get
like really antsy and excited and
nervous but once something's been
rehearsed and you get that practice time
in I guess my goal is to achieve the
state of non-thinking
that's the ideal and that's the most
exciting because it just feels like pure
enjoyment there you are hanging off the
skyscraper and people look up and
suddenly there's a stage there's art
there's beauty there's grace there's
power in this sight that you overlook
every day
[Music]